Human to animal shapeshifting creatures are
a worldwide phenomenon.
Were-predatory beasts exist in a myriad of
forms:
werehyenas, weretigers, werepanthers, werejaguars…
but the werewolf is the most notorious of
them all.
There’s so much history behind the infamous
shapeshifters that we’re going to take two
episodes to trace the beginnings of the werewolf
in Europe through their entrance into modern
literature and pop culture.
The first thing to understand about the history
of the werewolf is that there is no single
origin.
Legends of these lupine shapeshifters are
so numerous and widespread, their pervasiveness
makes identifying one universal definition
or origin of the wolf-human monster challenging.
Despite the werewolf ’s widespread appearance
in folklore, I’ll admit I haven’t really
given the werewolf the attention it deserves—until
now.
[Monstrum intro]
​​The wolf has symbolized everything from
an admirable patron of warriors, to figures
for greed, and even as the Devil in disguise.
These near-silent, deadly predators were at
one point the most widely distributed land
mammal, claiming large swaths of the globe
as their hunting grounds—and wolves posed
a very real threat to humans and their livestock.
Still, we seemed to have admired the animals.
Our ancestors donned the skins of predators
while hunting, perhaps to camouflage themselves,
or to evoke the spirit of an animal during
the hunt, as archeological artifacts and ancient
art reveal.
Humans and wolves existed as both allies and
enemies.
While some wolves were eventually domesticated
for hunting and protection—
their wild brethren remained a threat.
These early connections set the stage for
a complex relationship between man, wolf,
and were-hybrid.
But does that mean werewolves were originally
a universal monster, or were there other factors
that came into play?
To understand the origins of the werewolves
more clearly, I reached out to Dr. Kaja Franck,
werewolf expert and visiting professor at
the University of Hertfordshire]
Wolves themselves exists in many different
countries and in many different continents.
And because of this, they have become powerful
symbols of the animal, other.
Wolves, and their behavior is often very similar
to how humans exist.
They live in families and they hunt as packs
and they predate on the same creatures that
we'd like to eat ourselves.
And so it makes sense that folklore would
absorb these creatures and they would recur
in myths and in legends.
And he would, would see them as existing on
the boundaries of what it was to be human
and what it was to be animal.
The connections between wolves and humans
are deeply ingrained in ancient literature
and lore.
These early stories seem to categorize werewolves
into three different types: the “victim”
where an innocent person is cursed to turn
into a wolf but maintains human reason; the
“damned” who are violent humans that become
wolves as a punishment to both their body
and soul; and the “warrior” where humans
take on the guise of the wolf to aid in success
in battle.
The oldest piece of surviving literature we
know about —The Epic of Gilgamesh—portrays
a “victim” werewolf in what is widely
considered the oldest werewolf story on record.
Written between 1300 and 1000 BCE it tells
of an unlucky shepherd whom the goddess Inanna,
turns into a wolf.
In contrast, werewolves of Ancient Greece
and Roman mythology are dominantly portrayed
as the “damned” werewolf, representing
a tradition of human to wolf transformations
distinguished by deviant deeds.
In the Greek text, Agriopas’ Olympionics,
a man is turned into a wolf for 10 years as
punishment for eating human entrails.
Cannibalism is a recurring theme in ancient
myths that use wolf transformation as a cautionary
tale.
Linking human cannibalism to wolves isn’t
that far-fetched; wolves are above all opportunistic
eaters.
In addition to scavenging animal corpses of
all kinds—including humans—wolves have
been known to eat the remains of their own
species.
In the first century CE, Pliny wrote Naturalis
Historia, associating human cannibalism with
wolf-like behavior and features.
About 8 CE, Ovid’s Metamorphoses interprets
another Greek legend about the god Zeus and
King Lycaon of Arcadia.
According to the story, the Roman god Jupiter
hears rumors that King Lycaon is practicing
human sacrifice and cannibalism, so he descends
to earth in human form to discover the truth.
Lycaon is unconvinced of Jupiter’s divinity,
and decides to put his omniscience to the
test.
He kills, butchers, and attempts to serve
human flesh to the god.
Jupiter is appalled by the crime, and the
deception, so he destroys the king’s household
in a mad rage.
A distraught Lycaon takes to the fields—howling.
Driven mad by his own misdeeds, he begins
to slaughter the flocks as a horrible transformation
takes place.
His clothes become hair, his arms turn to
legs—and he transforms fully into a wolf,
although his human eyes remain.
If the name Lycaon sounds familiar, your wolf
sense might be tingling.
The Greek word ‘lykos’ meaning ‘wolf’
and ‘anthropos’ meaning ‘man,’ inspired
the word lycanthropy or “wolf-man syndrome.”
The word was invented in the early second
century by the Greek physician Marcellus to
define a melancholy affliction
identified by the habit of frequenting cemeteries
and behaving like wolves and dogs.
The third ancient werewolf trope, the “warrior,”
is perhaps most famously associated with berserkers,
Ancient Nordic fighters who took on a predatory
animal’s characteristics in battle.
Bears, wolves, and boars were revered by berserkers,
and it was believed that literally donning
the skin of an animal allowed a transformation
to occur.
They would fight with crazed, seemingly preternatural
violence, howling and roaring on the battlefield.
Instead of separating humans from beasts,
this concept respects both in tandem.
However, psychological and physical shapeshifting
were seen as different concepts.
The berserker took on the spirit of the animal
but did not physically change form.
In the 13th century collection, Saga of the
Volsungs , werewolves appear multiple times.
In one story, a princess named Signy marries
a rival king, who in war kills her father
and captures her 10 brothers.
One by one, the brothers are eaten by a large
mysterious she-wolf.
This happens every night until only one, Sigmund,
is left.
With his sister's help and a little honey,,
Sigmund kills the wolf, believed to be a human
woman in disguise, by biting off her tongue."
The now-dead creature is believed to be Signy's
mother-in-law who had taken on a wolf form
through witchcraft.
In another example from the Saga, a thieving
father and son duo find two magic wolf pelts
in a forest hut.
They put on the skins, transform into wolves,
and are horrified to learn they cannot transform
back; unbeknownst to them, the skins can only
be removed every 10 days.
In wolf form, they decide to separate but
if they meet too much trouble on their own,
they should howl for help.
The son ignores this warning and manages to
kill 11 men before severely injuring himself.
After the 10 days pass, both men return to
human form.
Horrified by the experience they burn the
magic pelts.
As thieves, the two live separated from society,
embodying wolfish tendencies before turning
into literal wolves.
In the Norse language the word for wolf is
varg.
Since wolves were considered withdrawn and
solitary, varg inspired the word vargr—which
roughly translates to outlaw.
While some etymologists argue that the ‘wer’
in “werewolf’ comes from the Anglo-Saxon
word for ‘man’ other’s claim that the
extra ‘e,’ and the common variations of
‘war-‘ and ‘varg’ challenge this idea.
One thing that does seem clear is that from
the beginning of their infamous name, werewolves
have been associated with solitude and violence.
The etymology itself is somewhat complicated
and not always clear.
It said that it could come from the old English
or from the old German or from a mixture of
two.
What does seem to be clear is that it specifically
refers to the word man Wolf and by man, I
don't mean how we use the term man today,
meaning mankind, but rather masculine or male,
the male or masculine human.
And so werewolf necessarily means a male monster.
And this certainly has been the case that
we do find that there are definitely more
male werewolves than there are female werewolves.
The Germanic Nordic traditions spread across
Europe as its people did and that’s why
werewolf stories are found in indigenous Icelandic
sources
It’s also likely that Celtic werewolf stories
were likewise influenced by the Ancient Nordic
people, especially given that the strongest
werewolf tradition comes from Ossory, an area
with strong historical ties to vikings.
As the werewolf legend spread, different cultures
and geographic areas contributed their own
unique flourishes—resulting in a staggering
number of werewolf variations.
Serbian legend says one becomes a werewolf
if you drink water from the footprint of a
wolf.
Danish tradition dictates that only Danish
men can become werewolves.
Russian folk belief claims that a witch placing
her girdle under a house’s threshold on
the inhabitant’s wedding day will turn all
who are celebrating into wolves once they
cross over it.
The introduction of Christianity saw these
ancient beliefs and myths rewritten as “pagan”
and therefore sinful—so the werewolf became
something to be disproved and denied, through
mental illness or demonic influence.
Human to wolf transformation would be a defiance
of divinity—only God had the power to alter
something so completely.
The first recorded use of the word “werewolf”
appears in the 11th century in the Ecclesiastical
Ordinances of King Cnut (c. 1016-1035), where
it’s used symbolically to warn Christian
clergy to be on the lookout for those who
might threaten their congregation.
The differences and similarities in European
werewolves under Christianity reflect the
dominant anxieties and values of Europe during
the Middle Ages.
One such example emerged in the recurring
trope of the “Sympathetic Werewolf,” where
a human soul trapped in a wolf body could
be divinely saved if they showed their devotion
to God.
Celtic traditions of werewolves from the time
developed to shape the creature into victims
suffering from involuntary transformation,
a sympathetic interpretation that reflects
the heavy influence of Christianity in the
country,
as illustrated in archdeacon and historian
Gerald of Wales’s account of the landscape
and people of Ireland.
Published in the late 12th Century, Topographia
Hibernica, narrates an encounter between a
priest and a werewolf where the monster asks
the holy man for communion and last rites
for his wife—who is also a werewolf—a
fact that is revealed when the desperate male
werewolf pulls back her wolf skin to reveal
an elderly woman.
Perhaps the singular most important ‘Sympathetic
Werewolf’ tale of the 12th century is located
in Marie de France’s Bisclavret.
Published in the latter part of the century,
the French poem of a werewolf knight was translated
into Old Norse—broadening its readership.
The story focuses on a handsome, happily married
noble knight—who just so happens to disappear
from home every three days.
His wife accuses him of having an affair,
and he won’t defend his absence saying the
truth will only harm her.
The wife asks him again and again for an explanation
until finally, he says “My lady, I turn
bisclavret;/ I plunge into that great forest./
In thick woods I like it best./ I live on
what prey I can get.”
He’s naked when this happens and will not
tell her where he hides his clothes because
if they are lost he could stay a werewolf
forever.
After a bit of nagging, he reveals they are
under a bush at an old chapel.
The terrified wife devises a plan to escape
the marriage.
She and her lover steal her husband’s clothes
and when he never returns home, the lovers
marry.
A year later, the missing husband’s friend,
the King, is hunting in their woods when he
comes across Bisclavret in werewolf form.
Instead of killing the beast, the King spares
his life after the wolf shows his human side—kissing
his foot and leg.
The werewolf joins the King’s retinue and
is well cared for.
All is well until Bisclavret's wife’s new
husband attends the King’s feast and the
werewolf bites the knight and drags him away,
although the king manages to stop him from
killing the man.
Bisclavret is violent again when the King’s
hunting party comes across his scheming wife
and he attacks the woman—tearing off her
nose and face.
He is about to be killed when a “wise fellow”
proposes that his violence against these two
people shows he has a great grudge and speculates
the beast is the missing knight.
Under the King’s questioning, in pain and
fear the lady confesses to stealing the clothing.
The King demands its return, but Bisclavret
ignores the clothes, too ashamed to show the
“terrible” change “from the form of
a beast.”
Only when he is alone does Bisclavret don
the clothes, turning back to human form.
The lady and her knight are expelled from
the realm,
and in an interesting extension of the “werewolf’s
curse,” some of their female progeny are
born without noses.
Other European werewolf traditions grew as
well.
The “Sympathetic Werewolf” was joined
by the “Werewolf Lover.”
In these tales, a woman is attacked by a wolf
who rips off some of her clothes, usually
her apron or skirt.
Later, when he returns in human form, the
woman recognizes him as the werewolf by the
clothing or threads between his teeth.
In some versions, the women escape by throwing
off their clothing, which the werewolf attacks
instead.
Scholars often read these stories as symbolic
of sexual assault against women.
There is also the “Wounded Werewolf” a
trope where the male human form of the werewolf
is only revealed when the beast is struck
by a knife or a piece of wood.
Now that his human identity is revealed, he
is no longer a threat.
Then there are the “Back Rider” or “Wolf-Rider”
stories, where a man transforms into a werewolf
with the help of a special belt or skin.
These werewolves would cling to the back of
a male victim.
During the Middle Ages, werewolf legends evolved
and expanded, becoming more widespread—and
more demonized by the Church.
Reports of werewolf activity increased.
Barry Lopez and his book of wolves and men
suggest that one of the reasons why the way
that the werewolf was changing in terms of
depiction was in part because of the way wolves
were being seen in the 14 hundreds in Europe,
farming was changing and it was becoming more,
um, about sheep and sheep became a center
of the economy within Europe.
Now, unfortunately not only did humans like
sheep, but so did wolves.
And suddenly there was a sense that wolves
were predating, that wolves were destroying
expensive sheep
and because of the preexisting symbolism within,
uh, religion, within Christianity, regarding
the Wolf and sheep, as God's flock, it quite
nicely fitted in together that the Wolf became
seen as more monstrous and monstrous.
And therefore the wealth became seen as more
and more monstrous.
And that a transformation into the Wolf was
necessarily an evil thing, most likely caused
by the enemy of God, the devil.
As werewolf stories continued to rise in popularity,
the Church’s stance on the creature changed.
Where before, it was an official sin in the
Christian Church to believe in werewolves
because it suggested that beings other than
God could alter physical substance.
However, beginning in the later 16th century
it was considered heretical to not believe
in werewolves, a change that came after the
Church shifted its attention to persecuting
witches.
This change seems to be an attempt again,
to deal with the proliferation of werewolves,
but also to deal with the fact that the belief
and the myth of Wells doesn't seem to be going
anywhere.
And so it made more sense to suggest that
the devil literally could transform man into
Wolf.
And I think this is because the church saw
that it was far better to keep responding
and adapting and absorbing these beliefs rather
than absolutely refuting them.
Shape-changing into wolves became a component
in witchcraft accusations and was often accompanied
by charges of cannibalism.
Part of the rise of the so-called “werewolf
trials” is also due to a seminal text on
identifying and punishing witches— the Malleus
Maleficarum.
Co-authored by Catholic clergyman and inquisitors
Heinrich Kraemer and Johann Sprenger, after
its publication in 1486, this legal and theological
text not only became the standard for witch-hunting,
it served as a handbook for the approved torture
of those accused.
The text claimed some witches were able to
turn into wolves, although this metamorphosis
was an illusion rather than a true transformation.
It was the “Devil” who helped produce
glamours, a kind of magic that makes things
appear different from their true form, in
this case—making someone appear as a wolf.
This werewolf glamour increased strength,
speed, and intelligence, all advantages to
help them kill and eat humans.
Medieval Christian demonologists also believed
the Devil could appear in the form of a wolf.
The rise in Christian doctrine condemning
witchcraft is only one factor as to why cannibalistic
werewolf accusations rose.
The Black Death, or the bubonic plague, is
another.
By the end of the 14th century, it is estimated
that anywhere from 20 to 75% of the global
population succumbed to the Black Death.
Fewer people meant less encroachment on the
wolves’ natural habitat, and therefore the
wolf population grew.
In the 15th and 16th centuries, reports of
roving wolf packs increased.
They ate livestock and occasionally attacked
humans, which corresponded to an increase
in werewolf accusations throughout Europe.
In France belief in werewolves, or in loup-garou
--men destined to become wolves at the full
moon, were at an all-time high during the
Inquisition, with 30,000 reported cases between
1520-1630, not surprising given the aim to
combat heresy.
And when French colonizers traveled to places
like Canada, Haiti, and Louisiana, the loup-garou
took on additional characteristics as it encountered
the folklore of the indigenous and enslaved
peoples.
The myths and the ideas regarding werewolves
and wolves would travel to the new world with
the settlers and colonizers who came from
Europe.
These creatures that we had thought we had
destroyed or left behind in many ways, therefore
the landscape seemed to be a landscape of
nightmares.
Now, the colonizers made use in some ways
of these preexisting myths, it gave a function
for why wolves had to be destroyed.
Unfortunately, the hatred of wolves would
be misapplied as well to the indigenous population.
And so the way that Walzer this seen as Savage
and voracious creatures was used in intimately
recessed and violent terms against the native
Americans themselves and the death of the
walls was done alongside the death of the
native Americans.
Werewolf trials in Central and Western Europe
peaked in the early-17th century.the label
“werewolf” could be applied to someone
who engaged in heinous crimes outside of witchcraft—like
murder, cannibalism, and rape
In many cases the shapeshifting was less significant
than the murder and cannibalism associated
with the change.
In fact, during the 16th century, many of
the werewolf executions reported by the Catholic
Church involved confessions of eating human
flesh, particularly that of children.
No 16th-century werewolf gained more notoriety
than German farmer Peeter Stubbe.
It was said he had made a deal with the Devil
that allowed him to take the shape of a wolf
in order to kill men, women, and children
without getting caught—for over 25 years.
Stubbe was captured by a group of hunters
looking for the beast that had been slaughtering
their families and livestock.
Their dogs succeeded in chasing down a wolf,
but the hunters lost sight of it—only to
see Stubbe in the same spot the wolf had vanished.
The hunters assumed he had removed his werewolf
girdle and regained his human form, After
a little torture on the rack, he quickly confessed
to procuring the girdle, becoming a wolf,
murdering 14 children and 2 pregnant women,
He reportedly killed his own son and ate his
brain, committed incest with his daughter
and sister and was rumored to have a long
affair with a “she Devil” sent to him
by Satan.
His daughter and mistress were also tried
and found guilty as accessories to the murders
and on October 31, 1589, they were all executed.
Stubbe was laid on a wheel and burning pincers
were used to pull the flesh off his body.
His legs and arms were broken, and his head
was removed, the body burned to ash.
His daughter and mistress were burned to death
with his corpse.
Stubbe’s severed head was spiked on a pole
and displayed below a wooden carving of a
wolf.
The cruelty of the crimes and punishment were
immortalized in 1590 as an English narrative:
A True Discourse Declaring the Damnable Life
and Death of One Stubbe Peeter—the first
popular werewolf narrative in England that
reinvigorated Great Britain’s interest in
the monster after it had all but been eradicated
in the previous few centuries after aggressive
wolf cleansing campaigns.
The Stubbe case, and others like it, are today
recognized by many scholars as evidence of
early human serial killers rather than supernatural
werewolves.
This reflects a movement that began hundreds
of years before as history attempted to rationalize
or explain the actions of those who claimed
to be wolf shapeshifters.
While today there is a distinction between
the fictional werewolf and the condition of
lycanthropy, the two ideas were entwined for
most of history.
As early as the second century and well into
the 18th century, “Lycanthropy” could
refer to both the literal transformation of
human to wolf using magic
and to a form of mental illness where a person
believed they could become a wolf.
Today, physicians recognize ‘clinical lycanthropy’
or “lycomania” as a real disorder— a
rare condition where patients believe they
are transforming into or have transformed
into a non-human animal.
Another explanation behind werewolves is a
hallucination brought on by drugs.
Archeological and literary evidence suggests
that the ‘trance’ that endowed the berserkers
with supposed increased strength and speed
may have been caused by the ingestion of hallucinogenic
mushrooms.
Another commonly cited hallucinogen that may
have contributed to werewolf delusions is
outbreaks of ergot poisoning.
The fungus can infect rye, wheat, barley,
and oats—common food sources—and when
ingested causes hallucinations and physical
symptoms like uncontrollable body movements,
panic attacks, a burning sensation, and gangrene.
As recently as in 1951, victims of ergot poisoning
in France reported werewolf hallucinations.
Yet another proposed medical explanation for
werewolf lore is . Also called “werewolf
syndrome” or “Ambras syndrome.”
The disease causes extreme hair growth that
often covers the entire body.
Documented since the 17th century, it is a
recognized condition today believed to be
caused by gene mutation.
An excess of hair in unusual places was often
cited as evidence of a werewolf in their human
form, so some accused werewolves may have
just been suffering from this condition.
Then in the 20th century, two new explanations
appeared: porphyria and rabies.
Porphyria is a rare genetic disease characterized
by severe photosensitivity that results in
some stereotypical werewolf traits: hyperpigmentation,
excessive hair growth, nocturnal wandering,
and red or reddish-brown teeth.
The rabies virus causes crazed and frenzied
behavior in animals (including wolves) who
are driven to more aggressive behavior when
the virus attacks the brain, often against
other animals and even humans.
In humans, symptoms include difficulty swallowing,
increased thirst, inflammation of the brain,
hypersexuality, irrational fear of water,
contraction of the lips—and although extremely
rare, the desire to bite other humans.
I can't count the number of times that people
have explained to me that the reason why anyone
has ever believed in werewolves is because
of porphyria or ergot poisoning or hyper hirsutism.
And I find this a really flawed way of thinking
about where wolves and monsters more generally.
I think tried to explain the way beliefs actually
destroys the power and the wonder of the supernatural
and also the symbolism and importance of monsters.
I think really it's far better to allow werewolves,
to remain a creature that can be interpreted
in a multiplicity of different ways.
And for us to understand that where wolves,
wolves, and other monsters remain powerful
symbols within the human imagination.
The proposed explanations for werewolves aren’t
quite as numerous as the different variations
of this monster, but they indicate a desire
to understand strange and deviant behavior.
Given that wolves were at one point the most
common and dangerous land-based predators
in Europe and did pose an immediate threat
to humans, their connection to witchcraft
and werewolves—other perceived threats to
humanity—isn’t all that surprising.
Fear of the werewolf in the Medieval and Early
Modern period seems to be about the possibility
that the body is malleable.
The mental capacity to shed one’s identity
so dramatically, into another “body” or
persona that seems more monstrous, violent,
and unpredictable, may have helped us explain
the crimes humanity can commit against one
another.
The werewolf is one of the most well-known
monsters we’ve covered on Monstrum, and
one that has endured for centuries.
But why?
In part two of the series, we’ll cover how
the Werewolf has continued to claw at our
modern imagainations.